[Music]
hey useful Yama so you're teaching G
yeah this is Eugene Lee and this is his
son you lean you together they create
incredible sculptures out of scrap metal
whatever solutions with another didn't
eat me and how if we got kind of sushi
because in the advice yeah I hear more
so I feel ya ah this father-son duo got
their start making models of
transformers newer hotter aw binging gun
hassles or she is open innovation that
can delay your agency today and so even
she tells her that way she actually she
she's a lot of users right Teagan one
Java tanio koba Reba ot go most
important up yo damn you are and you
know the Wharton desire you got about
also meet the father and son went on to
expand the business beyond just
transformers and began building their
own designs channel so woman singing
consider the Shannon Lee Street and also
help you with um a girl named Jennifer
Tilly go the axillary users in town so
on butter and oversell the new suitable
to her threats are in the tally
Mizuki
[Music]
hezonia girls I see a total of off and
they puzzles really felt like an
environment like a never you get up so
[Music]
tight cope I'm in Baja and then go to
what she window and come I just show
more but I got total come home and you
what kind of parts of the hallway today
you can catch it back so you got was
like a lot of the underlying then
chokehold on a single over well you have
it all tradução woody yeah Roger
Oh Monty I'm looking over don't you
[Music]
watch a little too much on Ukrainian
control the Andrea Neutron will show me
later tomorrow no children what a
Pavarotti with a cobra literature I want
a car to show Jimmy o Shah Mardan there
are copied over too much Suzanne Jana
tell each other the tree on certain a
fatal of what one woman younger children
should say how they hold a player well
what kind of a challenge here just a
woman home to gardenia earn a cash
reward which is their orders at come to
serve mine with a one time my mother to
go wash my mother take a fan saw module
- who are you - where are the quani it's
a way to how that woman a woman
t-midi girl you know you go to her the
Nora Teresita I want some Gran Canaria
children Konoha - a woman the tunas are
kind of to be super efficient
[Music]
- original mode each other even though
cover so much 200-year first you take a
miracle Easter the baby they took a
proof photo here that the antenna type
womanly under that he broke down whether
saw a woman come with you make another
one which is hanjiro oh my daughter you
got the target
[Music]
Associates un poco los Deportes a
femenino Mascarene oh no la syncro up to
all mentio india
sevilla woman deporte feminino i care
improve our eras en esta casa por Movado
me so power rebus tengo venti dos años y
me different attend antistick oh not a
sin artistic a grant a slow guerra
conocido como not asean synchronize Dada
es como el valle 10 el agua para ser un
buen synchronise 'te tienes que saber
nada obviamente peripartum ustedes que
tenia notre squalid a desk a no tiene
los de natashia no prompt lo a flexible
Eva severe by Lara expresser con el
puerto yoga's nose multi-fit allez met
every day fear an email a todos des
portes Yodas epigonion adavi own
teammate open poco con la synchro en
Doan a spectacle on Barcelona yo tenía
CD on sentences cuando lo ve me intro
por los ojos me in con todo que e
[Music]
cuando un peso lrf inartistic ah
so lobby on chicas interface Miguel Paco
from Paco's aprendido no no no me lo
esperaba y el propio club también se que
dar un poco parados non-plan moon Chico
Guerra hair sing grow is in poco raro No
[Music]
I see the knowledge lasts until good up
okay when ya sabes lo T peak okay
technically con
oh yes commentary oh say up incipio
condo you empathy no Mia Hamm
participate independently campeonatos
it's 2:00 a.m. tiempo parado pero por
suerte encontre a los Pantera's Gravas
las Pantera's Prabhas es una so sassy
own la gente beiieve Chico City cos que
hace muchos de portes a super low Sophia
un poco de los Pantera's drogas es que
todo mundo de cualquier sexo de
cualquier a mentally de es Libre para
hacer cualquier a porter que quiera
porque esto del sex is mode ambien no
solo pass a la synchro tambien esta
pasando a nodos des portes entrer todos
tenemos que el international in those
milky safe
Cara meant a probe aren que los chicos
podemos participar Anabel Olimpico no no
no sana bravado llegar see pudiera an
evil Olimpico a participant imperious
area ro no amaz no pero que espero como
de por teesta yo on PA no barreras con
con todos los chicos no queso mossad el
mundo el finales estar en el agua que
para me es lo mejor que puede ver no say
yo scummy segunda castle agua de estado
de Libertad
[Music]
[Music]
Pop's the mid-tour aren't I
Nicole Paris the princess beatboxing is
just simply making sounds with your
mouth making music with your mouth when
beatbox came to Saint Louis in the early
80s it was always about emulating what
the DJ did so I just thought of
perfecting my skill as I got older and
then my wife she gets pregnant with
Nicole so I would be box up against the
building at Nikolas thought twisting you
will see my wife's belly almost like
boom she liked that she thought it was
funny and cute and then to ask Nicole
got bigger in the belly
it wasn't cheat no more at the age of 13
was my first talent show I just went
home when I said pops are just drawing
the talent show you want to teach me how
to beatbox he taught me how to hold a
mic
tell me how to breathe taught me the
basic beat I went to the talent show did
that they made me mad at the talent show
they was clapping offbeat and it was
like I then started to add my own thing
to what he taught me one night I came
home from work and as I'm walking in the
door I heard her making all these
strange noise I had to tell him like
that's not beatboxing I don't do that
that's corny I like well this is when I
had to realize and tell myself look this
is what she wants to do
me and pops we be box anywhere all day
don't even know if we really don't we be
box my cooking barbershop when we ready
to beatbox it literally happens doesn't
matter if you go to her YouTube
challenge you will see us sitting down
beatboxing it's yourself folks and it
can look like a competition we're not
really battling it's just it's just jam
session just us having fun this this is
how I bonded my child even though she
loves pop loser I want her to be the
best I want her to to outdo me not in an
outdo me like as in a battle but I want
her to just just continue to grow and
add to beatboxing
[Music]
my ultimate goal is just to have my name
up there with my dad's name when they're
picking some of the best drivers in the
industry to work on a big car show you
know I don't want to be the best woman
driver the best black woman driver I
want to be the best driver and one of
the best drivers don't get too cocky
because the Naing of the other work
[Music]
my name is Brianna Lynch I'm 21 years
old and I've been a stunt driver for
four and a half years my name is Julie
Oh J Lynch I'm her dad
and I've been in the business for 27
years all the dangerous stuff that the
cars are doing in the movies all the
exciting stuff we do that and not the
actors so a couple of the films that
I've worked on our Black Panther Proud
Mary Fast and Furious 8 Beyonce's music
video formation and creepy and that's me
and my dad right there I got started in
the business to a New Jack city I've
done all the Fast & Furious series since
number four in Jumanji and I'm one of
the guys up there on the bike yep that's
me right there so cool because I am the
cool this one time when my dad and I are
working together we actually like to
help each other set the cars up so when
I have to do something like sliding
around the corner my dad is right there
with me trying to make sure that
everything is set up so I think that's
what makes my dad and I really unique I
[Applause]
got into stunt driving because of my dad
they taught me how to ride when I was 3
years old he's been teaching me my
entire life he's so good at what he does
and so respected in this industry so
since I started son driving he has been
my motivator and my coach my teacher
he's everything about my accountant
pretty much
one of the things that I had learned by
riding with her all the time was that
she was able to handle the pressure 3 2
1 action as much as people don't believe
that you're inside a car when they
explode people are in those vehicles so
it's a lot to let your kid go and be in
danger I guess part of being a parent
and part of being in the stunt business
we do as much as we can to keep her as
safe as possible and then after that you
wish for the best
I love that I get to share stunt driving
with my dad I think that's a really cool
bond that the two of us have my dad and
I always been very close he's very
supportive of me chasing down this dream
that I have and if you want to be good
at something you have to put the time in
it's important for you to enjoy your
life and to actually love what you're
doing that's the biggest picture at the
day
[Music]